well I'm in therapy high five
I'm going to be in therapy
forever for me a relationship is what
catalyzed the necessity of said therapy
and the the reflection of how
disconnected from all of myself that
I've been
self-abandoning I guess I could say and
a lot of like statues of myself it's
like aspects of myself Frozen in time
because at some point in time I didn't
have the resources or the capacity to
address it uh and feeling afraid to love
afraid to open myself up to love because
I don't trust love because I'm afraid
that I will be hurt and I think that's
the definition of trauma I historically
have had somewhat of an allergy of sorts
to different buzzwords like that doing
the work trauma you know re-parenting
and then you you get involved and you're
like oh my God this is actually a thing
holy why am I crying right now